on dormait dans les arrêts de bus sur
les genoux de ma mère et mes frères ça a
duré pendant 3 mois et voilà on a connu
la souffrance mais plus plus que
[Musique]
je m'appelle Arsène du monde de boxe en
lourd léger en division WBA j'ai 35 ans
arrivé en France à l'âge de 7 ans on a
mené la vie très très dure en Arménie
j'ai perdu mon père à l'âge de 2 ans à
la guerre ma mère la pauvre il nous a
élevé seul ils nous vivait dans une dans
une petite maison de 30 m² à 4 j'ai 2
grands frères qu'on avait pas d'argent
c'est très dur ma mère voilà et
travailler à l'école maternelle et elle
me ramener avec elle à la maternelle on
a choisi de venir en France de pouvoir
mieux vivre et c'est ce qui s'est passé
on est arrivé en 97 je me rappelle
encore quand on est arrivé il y avait à
l'époque le 115 appelé le 115 je crois
que c'était à 22h le soir mais jusqu'à
là en fait je devais tourner tu devais
attendre on avait rien à l'époque
c'était un front donc à peu près 20
euros 20 euros dans la journée que les
assistances il te donnaient et qui
étaient obligés de de finir la journée
avec à 4 tu vas manger tourner voir des
choses à Paris pendant un mois passé tu
vois tout dépendait les jours mais on
dormait dans les arrêts de bus sur les
genoux de ma mère et mes frères ça a
duré pendant trois mois on a plus le 115
le soir du coup il nous loger et le
matin à 7h il fallait partir à 22h le
soir et le matin 7h il faisait sortir de
l'hôtel et voilà on a connu la
souffrance mais plus plus que ça on
faisait les visiteurs tous regardez
Paris on se promenait on partait dans
les parcs et vraiment c'était c'était
très très difficile aujourd'hui quand je
suis à Paris quand je tourne à chaque
fois il y a il y a une image que je vois
de de peu importe parc Monceau par
exemple ou les champs il y a toujours un
endroit que tu sais quand tu as passé 7
ans tu marques toujours un point et je
me rappelle très très bien et je disais
j'appelle ma mère dit maman tu te
rappelles ici appelle mon frère j'ai dit
oh tu te rappelles et c'est ce qu'on
faisait de 97 à 2000 on ne dit à Paris
et nous on voulait partir au sud parce
que ma mère elle s'est fait opérer de
l'hernie discale le docteur il a dit le
seul endroit pour qu'elle se sent bien
il fallait dans une ville chaud où il
fait chaud à 200 à Lyon à Miribel je me
rappelle encore c'était dans un foyer on
recevait les gens de voilà c'est là que
je suis parti la première fois à l'école
à toute première fois tu vois je
comprenais pas le français ils avaient
une classe au collège pour les autres on
font étrangères avaient de tout à cette
époque encore il y avait la guerre au
Kosovo je me rappelle beaucoup de
kosovar Albanie tout ça et on était tous
entre nous qui était bien on avait parlé
avec les
pieds mais c'était des bons moments
c'était des très bons moments après
avoir la petite à petit on a commencé à
prendre par les Français et ainsi de
suite sixième 5e et après trois ans
trois ans passés à Lyon on a fait la
demande de là et les papiers en
2000-2001 on a fait la demande pour pour
prendre un HLM en fait et du coup il y a
pas eu de place et finalement ils ont
trouvé Carcassonne c'était hyperactif
depuis tout petit du coup voilà à
l'école beaucoup de beaucoup de bagarre
on faisait le con quoi il y avait un mot
qui faisait déjà de la boxe Sofiane ça
se rappelle à Carcassonne et un jour il
m'a dit on était tous les deux dans la
même collège en fait on est de la compte
il m'a dit voilà il m'a dit tu veux tu
veux pas en faire j'y vais vas-y on va
en faire et mon frère il en avait marre
aussi il m'a dit ben vas-y au moins si
tu te tu te bats dans tu vas dans dans
un ring et au moins tout le monde tout
le monde tout le monde applaudir mais là
tu tu dois à l'extérieur ça sert à rien
en fait tu vois tu veux ça va rien
t'apporter dans la vie du coup voilà je
commence là-bas chez mon mec bowling à
BC Carcassonne je suis resté deux ans
jusqu'à que qu'on trouve un appartement
à Toulouse parce qu'on voulait partir la
ville voilà mes frères il voulait vous
les réussir et on voulait avancer dans
l'avion en général et je connais la la
box de Blagnac à l'âge de à l'âge de 16
17 ans et voilà je connais
du coup il a trouvé avec l'ancien
président personnel il est décédé
aujourd'hui avec Botella Botella qui a
trouvé un appartement pour nous on
s'installe à Toulouse et à partir de là
tout s'est ouvert dès qu'on a
l'appartement en fait on arrive mon
frère il ouvre sa société sa société
voilà dans la maçonnerie peinture il
fait un peu de tout et moi qui a
toujours aimé travailler peu importe en
fait comment ça travaille avec lui à
l'aider un peu voilà mon autre frère
pareil le temps que en fait je rentre en
équipe de France purement que que je
m'installe à l'INSEP du courage on a
commencé à travailler avec lui voilà je
gagne un peu ma vie comme ça et à
l'époque 50 euros c'était quelque chose
tu vois mon époque j'avais 17 18 ans du
coup à chaque fois de la journée quand
je travaille me pensais tout le temps le
soir 50 €, tu vois c'était énorme 50 €,
17 ans ça va c'est bien et ainsi de
suite après voilà le temps que je rentre
avec de France je rentre en équipe de
France il a commencé à travailler voilà
il a grandi sans société et moi je suis
devenu champion de France junior senior
et je suis resté pendant deux ans en
équipe de France Inter on a fait des
tournois à l'extérieur médaille d'or
médaille de bronze médaille d'argent un
peu de tout finalement je suis rentré à
Toulouse en 2012 et j'ai signé
professionnel le 27 mai 2012 déjà quand
tu arrives de des amateurs tu as pas la
la Vision Pro en fait tu crois que c'est
les amateurs mais ça n'a rien à voir si
notre monde tout est différent les
entraînements sont différents ta vie tu
dois le changer quand l'homme matin on
faisait des conneries plein de conneries
on sortait on très très tard le long de
matin en partie courir avec l'équipe et
quand tu arrives en fait chez les trop
dans ta ville t'as pas d'argent tu veux
travailler en même temps la foi et
t'entraîner chez les pros c'est des six
secondes de 3 minutes voir des huit et
10 et c'est très difficile mais pour
t'adapter il faut que tu tu tu t'adapte
rapidement et que tu mets un peu le
mauvais de l'extérieur de côté parce que
ce qui tue un boxeur c'est la rue et la
rue faut oublier un moment donné et
attends toujours des amis tu sais ouais
mon frère mon frère veut on sort mon
frère mais tu vois que en fait ils te
font plus couler que d'avancer tu vois
et là tu dois faire un tri tu dois
mettre le frère de côté et celui qui te
dit oh mon ami rentre à la maison et
pense à ton entraînement demain et plus
être proche de lui et c'est ce qui s'est
passé j'ai mis beaucoup de gens de côté
et voilà je mener ma vie ainsi jusqu'au
jusqu'à que je deviens un champion de
France professionnelle champion de Coupe
de France et jusqu'au 2007 pendant 2 ans
je galérais travailler dans les boîtes
de nuit à aider encore mon frère on
faisait de la peinture dans ma sonnerie
je faisais tout ce qu'il y avait à faire
en fait je fais un crédit à la banque et
je vous a deux épiceries de nuit de
travailler je m'entraînais j'ai
travaillé je m'entraînais je faisais que
ça et les épices du livre vous savez
c'est 7h du soir jusqu'à 3h du matin et
le lendemain à 7h je parcourir je vais à
la salle je fais ma séance les abdos ce
qui va avec le soir de 18h jusqu'à 20h
je m'entraînais je m'étais parfois mon
frère pendant une heure deux heures et
après je partais il restait jusqu'à 3h
du matin j'ai eu de 2014 que 4 ans
jusqu'à 2018 quand je deviens champion
du monde et là je les ai vendus parce
que je me disais aussi que peut-être ça
va s'arrêter du jour au lendemain donc
il faut avoir quelque chose à côté voilà
pour pouvoir vivre payer les loyers tu
vois vivre comme comme tout le monde
s'habille bien voilà conduire des belles
voitures ce que je n'ai pas vu quand
j'étais petit et pourquoi pas la voir au
fur et à mesure dans la vie quand tu
avances je te dis si il a fait qui je
suis de pas pouvoir le faire le bon Dieu
nous a donné des bras déjà des yeux pour
pouvoir le faire merci à ma mère elle
nous a mis sont des belles voix en
disant que mon fils tu peux le faire
donc fais-le si tu aimes quelque chose
va jusqu'au bout ne t'arrête jamais au
milieu de la route pour revenir à la box
je voulais vraiment le faire jusqu'au
bout la box en français très dur très
très difficile déjà pour s'en sortir il
faut des promoteurs il faut de la télé
il faut un budget il faut des sponsor et
quand tu t'en sors de ce difficulté pour
être reconnu faut être reconnu et de
dire que il a fait la différence parmi
tant et parmi ces clubs parmi ces
boxeurs et je pense que on n'est pas
assez reconnu je vais juste à peine pour
ton champion du monde depuis le 24 mars
2018 on est en 2023 là juste cette année
je vu que il y a un changement vu que
petit à petit le monde me reconnaisse le
monde en France que ça soit la rue que
je vais dans un resto je vois des gens
qui s'approchent qui prennent des photos
je me dis à haute ça commence à matcher
mais ça a mis du temps quand même 4 ans
c'est énorme alors quand tu deviens je
suis revenu du monde de foot ou de
tennis que ça soit Nadal que ce soit
l'équipe de France on parle de de
Killian qui qui je suis un grand faim ce
que je veux dire s'ils sont trop mis en
avant la box prend des coups sont fermés
et très loin de sa famille de son de son
cocon de son bien-être de rien voir de
pas assister à des anniversaires de pas
faire son anniversaire pendant 5 ans il
faut le faire le 4 octobre pendant 5 ans
j'étais en préparation à prendre des
coups et ça tombait toujours les jours
d'Espagne lundi à mercredi ensemble il
faut le faire loin de ta mère loin de
tes frères comptable logique contre
qu'on te souhaite au téléphone tu devais
un robot et c'est ce qui s'est arrivé
quand je rentre à la maison j'étais
robot j'étais enfermé à moi-même je
parle avec personne pourtant j'avais
gagné et j'étais là et voilà en fait
petit à petit tu te rends compte que en
fait c'est très dur quand c'est dur
surtout qu'on te donne pas cette cette
lumière alors ce que tu tu vis c'est
vraiment c'est dur il faut il faut avoir
un montant en acier et rester debout et
je pense que le bonjour m'a donné ça et
jusqu'aujourd'hui que je suis il vaut
mieux que courir un peu partout et qui
sait pas ce que tu auras l'image que tu
as dans le ring parce que les gens te
reconnaissent tu vois tu deviens tu
deviens on va dire le les jeunes de des
enfants tu vois il y a des gens qui
m'appellent ils me parlent comme si je
suis tu vois je sais pas Robert Vignon
vraiment et comment je suis resté très
humble dans ma vie en sachant tout qui
je suis qui j'étais et quand je vois
aujourd'hui des jeunes tu vois je leur
dis les gars je fais ça sans ça moi je
viens de d'une d'un pays qui a 3
millions d'habitants je viens d'un petit
quartier de
Erevan qui avait rien et finalement on
regarde où je suis comment je vis est-ce
que je fais aujourd'hui et sur quelle
chaîne je passe sur les radios surtout
tout est possible